welcome to the man of Recaps this is the
full series recap of succession Logan
Roy is a media Tycoon owner of the mega
Corporation waystar royco but now on the
eve of his 80th birthday he's ready to
retire going to leave the company in the
hands of his son Kendall Kendall's been
training for this his whole life but he
kind of just blew a big deal and Logan's
a real tough love kind of dad son you're
a huge disappointment you don't have
that killer instinct so his dad calls a
family meeting where it's like you know
I think I'm not gonna retire so with
Kendall no longer The Heir Apparent his
siblings are ready to fight for that top
spot and it's Game of Thrones in the
modern corporate world the oldest
brother Conor Roy from Logan's first
marriage isn't involved in the business
he's doing his own thing their younger
brother Roman is kind of a screw-up who
doesn't take anything seriously but now
that it's out there he's like yeah why
not me their sister Siobhan shiv doesn't
work at the company she's got a
successful career as a political
consultant but now that CEO is up for
grabs she's like yeah I mean I'd crush
it ship's fiancee Tom wamscams is
climbing up that corporate ladder he
grew up middle class and is desperate to
impress her rich powerful Dad new to the
Inner Circle is cousin Greg who recently
lost his job at waystar and has come to
ask his uncle for a new one but Greg is
hilariously not used to this
high-powered New York lifestyle it's Tom
who takes Greg under his wing and kind
of bullies him but is like nah man I'm
just razzing yeah but also I'm kind of
serious so Logan Roy is considering
which of his children can take his place
but immediately there's a shake up when
he has a stroke it looks like he'll live
but he's out of commission for a bit so
they do name Kendall acting CEO but
general counsel Jerry Kellman has some
bad news the company's got some huge
debt that'll be called in if the stock
price drops too far and it's currently
plummeting because their dad's health
issues so they might lose the company
immediately so Kendall pays a visit to
his best friend Stewie who's a classic
douchebag Finance bro now by the way the
stakes of the show are not that high
because at any point they can sell out
and happily retire as billionaires
before this family the monies are given
they want the power and Prestige so
Kendall convinces Stewie not to buy them
out but to buy in and save it so
Kendall's doing a decent job but his dad
does not agree he rushes his recovery to
get back in the office and start
undermining Kendall he makes it clear
he's not retiring anytime soon so
Kendall's gonna have to push him out he
works with Logan's longtime top advisor
Frank to Stage a coup and have the board
vote him out due to health concerns one
of the votes they hope to get is Logan's
brother Yuen Greg's Grandpa who's a real
grumpy Ai and absolutely hates his
brother Logan so Kendall slides in there
like hey help me push him out but ewan's
like whoa that's slimy bro I don't like
you either but even without him they
have the votes but on the day of the
meeting Kendall's stuck in traffic so he
has to call in to make a speech about
how his dad can't handle it which
doesn't have the same effect when
Logan's the one who's actually in the
room everyone who's on the fence backs
down by the time Kendall gets there his
coup has failed his dad is none too
pleased fires everyone involved yeah
when you play the game of thrones you
win or you die so with his brother all
the way out Roman steps up takes more
responsibility but he's not good at that
work part he's more of an ideas guy shiv
is still working in politics now
advising presidential hopeful Gil Edis
his whole platform has taken down
corporations like waystar but that's
fine by shiv fighting her dad is how
she'll learn his respect her fiance Tom
has been promoted and brought Greg with
him as his executive assistant Greg is
still new to this world so Tom's like
hey bro let me teach you how to be rich
which apparently involves eating
endangered species now Tom just took
over the cruise division but to get some
bad news back in the 80s there's a ton
of sexual harassment and it was all
covered up and it's a huge Scandal
waiting to blow so Tom makes Greg
destroy the evidence but Greg's actually
pretty smart he decides to keep copies
adjusting Gates Kendall's been doing his
own thing trying to Rebrand himself as a
cool venture capitalist but now he meets
with Stewie who has a confession the
money he invested with secretly came
from Sandy Furness his father's biggest
business rival so together he and
Kendall have enough stock for a hostile
takeover get their dad out put Kendall
in so it all comes to a head shiv and
Tom's wedding a lovely Affair despite
some huge family drama Roman thinks it's
funny to bring as a date to the girl
from Tom's bachelor party and the
satellite launch he rushed as a wedding
present uh does not go well Conor's date
is his longtime girlfriend Willa but
she's less of a girlfriend and more of
an escort but they've just taken the big
Next Step from occasional escort to
full-time sugar baby and when Conor
meets politician Gil Eve as he realizes
he wants to get into politics starting
with President of the United States and
Chip and Tom themselves have a complex
relationship she loves him but also
she's been cheating on him all season
with her co-worker but to her it was no
big deal it's like we're rich I thought
it was a given we could bang whoever we
want uh that was news to Tom though but
the biggest drama comes from Kendall
launching a hostile takeover of the
family company it's like bro on my
wedding night and Kendall feels bad
sorry it's just business but that's the
problem with the family business it's
not just business it's family now come
had a drug problem but he's been sober
for a while but after getting fired he
decided being sober's lame and tonight
he is very not sober and drives with the
caterer to buy some more drugs but oh no
they crash into the river and Kendall
makes it out but that poor kid dies
Kendall doesn't know what to do so he
goes back to the wedding and dances but
he is freaking out by the morning his
dad's security team has already covered
up Kendall's involvement it's okay son
let your dad take care of it and that's
what Kendall needs right now rushes back
to his father's arms so in season two
Kendall backs out of the Takeover he's
working at waystar again a shell of a
human being just does whatever his dad
wants Stewie and Sandy are very upset
with him and this doesn't stop the
Takeover it just makes it harder gonna
be a long drawn-out War so Logan calls a
family meeting hey do we want this fight
or is it time we cash out with our
billions of dollars he talks to the kids
one by one to get their pitch on the
future of the company Siobhan's like
well I haven't really thought about it
but it's clear she thought about it a
lot and so he tells her shiv it's you
and they make the secret deal shiv will
be the next CEO she gives Tom the good
news but their original plan he was
going to be CEO and she's like oh don't
worry baby you'll still be way high up
just you know under me in fact right now
Tom's promoted again out of cruises to
the big leagues news naturally he brings
his buddy Greg with him uh they continue
to get up to Shenanigans so Schiff comes
in starts working at the company to get
some experience before they can announce
so now all three siblings are working
together fighting each other for their
dad's approval which is Logan's dream
come true Roman needs help from someone
experienced and makes a secret alliance
with Jerry who advises him to show his
daddy serious by taking the way star
Management program now we've seen that
Roman has some issues with sex namely he
doesn't like it turns out what really
turns him on is when Jerry calls him a
pathetic failure and a disgusting
pervert and these two form an
interesting relationship the main thing
this season is fighting the Takeover
Logan's plan is to expand get so big
they can't get bought out so he wants to
buy Pierce Global media their biggest
news competitor but Nan Pierce wants to
ensure her company would be in good
hands so they have a billionaire family
get-together where the Roy's have to
pretend to be good people for the
weekend they befriend the Bizarro
versions of themselves Kendall's is
Naomi Pierce who is also a recovering
addict uh not currently recovering by
the way Kendall does have an ex-wife and
a couple kids but it doesn't really come
up much so they impressed Nan enough
she's willing to sell if Logan names a
successor his daughter Siobhan a woman
woman whose liberal-ish this should be
no problem because [__] is the air
anyway but Logan refuses willing to blow
up the deal over it and so sheff
realizes her dad's changed his mind if
he ever even really meant it in the
first place if she wants the job she's
gonna have to fight for it now the
Pierce deal is still gonna go through
because Logan's back channeling with
their CEO Raya Jarrell but right as
Nan's about to sign a big bomb drops the
crew Scandal finally breaks now it's not
that bad they don't have proof but even
the allegations blow up the deal after
this Riot starts working for Logan in
fact they start sleeping together which
his wife Marsha does not appreciate but
now that she is their dad's new favorite
the kids band together to kill her not
actually kill they say that a lot but
what they mean is get fired with a
golden parachute Saraya throws Logan a
big surprise party where Roman buys him
the wrong soccer team and Kendall does a
super cringy rap and now as Logan
announces Reya as his successor shiv
doesn't stop it because she had warning
that the crew Scandal was about to blow
up which poisons Reyes tenure and she
immediately resigns and this time it's
serious with Congressional hearings they
blame it all on Leicester who was head
of cruises at the time say upper
management didn't know but when their
nickname for Lester was Uncle Moe it's
hard to claim you didn't know he was a
molester so they take the yacht out for
a big family meeting where it's like
look basically someone has to go to jail
they have a very polite discussion where
everyone argues how it should be
literally anyone except for themselves
naturally Logan himself was not even an
option so it's his loyal son Kendall
who's willing to take one for the team
but as he begins his big press
conference he goes off script and blames
it all on his dad yes he's come out of
his season-long Funk realized his dad is
not a good person and he should not be
protecting him and he can prove that his
dad signed off on the bad stuff because
cousin Greg kept those documents so in
season three it's all out war between
Kendall and his father he tries to
recruit two siblings like hey aren't you
guys tired of him not naming any of us
this is our moment to take him down and
split the kingdom and this is the dream
all three siblings working together
we've had brief glimpses of actual Good
Times where they kind of love each other
but they would split the kingdom with
Kendall on top and they all want the top
job it's no deal at least Kendall has
cousin Greg on his side finally Logan
brings him in for a meeting like hey kid
I like you but take this promotion and
side with me or I will end you but
Grandpa Ewing doesn't approve of Greg
siding with his evil brother so he cuts
Greg out of his will leaves it all to
charity instead so Greg spent season
three trying to sue Greenpeace Tom finds
a way to score points with Logan by
offering to go to jail if someone still
has to but then he spends All Season
obsessively freaking out about it now
the first part of this war is fought in
the media and Kendall's trying to Brand
himself as the cool woke CEO who's gonna
take down the corrupt establishment of
course his dad fights back and Kendall
laughs most of it off except for the
very serious personal stuff that really
hurts Kendall's feelings meanwhile the
Takeover from Sandy and Stewie is still
happening and this war between father
and son does not Inspire confidence in
big shareholders like Adrian Brody at
the annual meeting it could come to a
vote but neither side wants that because
they could actually lose everything so
Frank's up there trying to stall as long
as possible while they make a deal
Sandy's pretty sick these days so he
talks through his daughter also named
Sandy and at this pivotal moment Logan
is also sick he's totally out of it
because he forgot to take his meds so
Siobhan and Sandy have to cut their
fathers out and agree to a deal that
everyone can get behind so the company
is saved but the company still in
trouble being investigated by the
government normally Logan can go to his
friend the president to get this shut
down as the owner of a News Network he
has a lot of power over the president's
approval ratings we've seen before he's
made the president wait on hold but the
president does not stop the
investigation so Logan goes hard on him
his approval ratings plummet in fact he
went so hard the prisons decided not to
run again so the Roy family travels to
The Unofficial meeting where they're
going to choose the next Republican
nominee the kids all pitch for their
preferred candidates of course Connor's
preferred candidate is Connor Roy yes
this whole time he's still been running
for president in fact he's actually
gotten some traction on his platform of
abolish all taxes and yeah it's a
problem he has zero experience but on
the other hand he looks decently
presidential so it's a maybe but his
Kendall finally turns over Greg's
documents turns out they don't actually
implicate his dad directly the
investigation Fizzles out Logan Roy won
again and no one has to go to jail which
Tom is very happy about to cheer himself
up kindle throws a ridiculous 40th
birthday party but he has kind of a
mental breakdown and is really sad but
now it's time for another wedding their
mother who's getting remarried Love Is
in the Air as Conor proposes to Willa if
he's gonna be president he needs to be
married and she's like you know I've
come this far why not and Greg has it
off with Kindle's media manager but
dating her has increased his perceived
value so he skips a few rungs and hits
it off with the princess of Luxembourg
but shiv and Tom's marriage has some
problems he's starting to realize she
doesn't love him and her response is
well I don't love you but I love you you
know now there's a new big business deal
in the works because way star royco is
outdated they need to get into Tech if
they're going to survive they want to
buy the hot new streaming service Gojo
owned by Swedish Tech entrepreneur Lucas
Matson it's Roman who manages to land
the deal so Jerry texts him good work
and he's going to respond with a dick
pic but his dad also texted him good
work at the same time and he responded
to the wrong one just sent his father a
dick pic but the deal hits a snag when
Lucas sends a cryptic tweet that gets
everyone speculating in his stock price
soaring so Logan goes out to meet him in
person like what's the problem this is a
good deal but very early on Logan taught
us that a good deal is not a good deal
because it means the other party's
desperate and you gotta squeeze him for
all their worth and Lucas absolutely
senses that he's like no offense man but
you're the past I'm the future I should
buy you Logan would normally never
consider that but this guy's got the
business smarts and Killer Instinct that
none of his kids have he's maybe finally
a worthy successor so at the wedding
their dad is conspicuously absent they
realize he's trying to sell the company
out from under them which again would
leave them out of a job but with even
more billions of dollars boohoo they
recruit their brother Kendall to help
him stop it but Kendall's not doing
great he shaved his head as part of his
breakdown and actually almost drowned he
finally confesses his dark secret about
how he killed that kid back at ship's
wedding now the Roy siblings do not talk
about serious stuff ever they really
don't know how to comfort him Roman's
advice is like yo don't feel bad man
I've run over lots of people but while
these siblings are constantly fighting
at the end of the day they are the only
people that grew up with their dad and
understand each other so it's a
beautiful bonding moment now if all
three of them stay strong together it
was in their mom's divorce settlement
they have veto power over their dad so
it's finally happening The Sibling Trio
has banded together United in purpose to
depose their father then duke it out for
the top spot so they bust in to stop him
you can't sell this company's our
Birthright but he's like yo none of you
deserve it I've already won he saw this
coming and renegotiated that divorce
settlement they have no power he can do
what he wants but how did he get the
jump on them they didn't tell anyone the
only only person she had told was Tom oh
snap Tom finally betrayed her of course
bringing his best bro Greg with him so
in season four the Roy siblings are
working together going to build their
own Media Company their father Logan Roy
is selling the company but he's not
retiring as part of the deal he's
spinning off the news division ATN and
he's got plans to make it bigger than
ever turns out he's using the money from
the deal to buy rival news station
Pierce that he always wanted the kids
realize why start a new company one
weekend by Pierce instead so they outbid
their father with an outrageous sum of
money for the emotional value of
sticking it to their dad now Logan Roy
almost feels a human emotion of missing
his kids on his birthday the only one
around is his son-in-law Tom walmsgams
and he and shiv are separated right now
after he betrayed her last season but
you know it's complicated and of course
sticking with Tom is cousin Greg and
Greg's not as much of an outsider as he
was at the beginning of the series he's
really become the classic corporate
douchebag so on the day of Connor's
wedding their debt's not coming he's
flying to Europe to finish the Gojo deal
but the kids get a phone call from the
plane their father died wait what yeah
for real this time another stroke or
something that did him in yes it's it's
an incredible emotional episode we get
from the kids perspective here as it's
all the confusion over the phone wait
what do you mean what's going on but
soon they come to accept this is really
it and are devastated as they try to
Rapid Fire process their complicated
relationship with him that they had
hoped to have another 20 years to
resolve as for poor Connor this kind of
ruins his wedding day and while Conor's
often kind of a joke character who's
marrying his former escort they've
actually developed kind of a healthy
supportive loving relationship in their
own way it's heartwarming but now with
Logan Roy dead the scheming for
succession is kicked into high gear
everyone's making their pitch to be the
next CEO uh some candidates taken more
seriously than others The Sibling dream
team's been closer than ever but they
still each think it should be them so
for now Kendall and Roman agreed to be
joint CEOs what about shiv yeah three is
just too many and it's no big deal it's
just temporary anyway they're still
going to sell the company to Gojo and
spin off the ATN Pierce deal the three
siblings United but now the boys get a
taste of that power Kendall really wants
to be the CEO and Roman really enjoys
firing people including Jerry his former
Ally then their complex relationship so
Kendall and Roman decide to try to kill
the Gojo deal and stay as CEOs and they
do not tell shiv which would leave her
high and dry so instantly realizing what
her brothers are up to shiv decides to
align with Matson to help make the deal
go through and so there's a ton of
scheming as The Sibling dream teams
pretending to be United but are all
secretly working against each other shiv
and Tom start to mend their relationship
things are better than ever between them
but then they have a blowout fight and
things are worse than ever between them
which is then made more complicated when
she reveals she is pregnant the big
sibling Showdown comes down to the
presidential election the front runner
is no friend to ATN and will let the
Gojo deal go through the other candidate
Jared Menken is by all counts a terrible
person who might dismantle American
democracy but he and Rome in our buddy
buddy and will happily kill the deal for
his friends the Roy's ships like come on
boys we can't elect a fascist but the
brothers are like well maybe we can
though if he's our fascist of course
there's a third option their brother
Connor Roy yes who's still running for
president Holden strong with his one
percent in fact that one percent is
enough to maybe swing the election so
Conor drops out and endorses mengan to
get the sweet ambassadorship now a new
station can't pick the president anyway
obviously it comes down to the votes but
in the confusion of election night when
ballots are lost ATN calls it for Menken
it'll be decided in the courts but it
gives them a lot of credibility and the
Roy boys have maybe just picked the next
president but when it's time for menkin
to honor his promise and kill that Gojo
deal he's non-committal yeah they
misplayed their hand he doesn't need him
anymore he'd rather support the deal
going through and work with Matson on
the condition that he names an American
CEO which would be his ally Siobhan so
it looks like shivroy is gonna be the
winner now the final decision on the
deal comes down to the board vote most
of the board likes the deal because it
would make them very rich so shiv and
Matt didn't look like they have it
unlocked Romans kind of given up but
Kendall has not so they all go down to
their mom's vacation house to try to
pitch Roman who could be a swing boat
meanwhile Tom is trying to pitch Lucas
on why in the world he should not be
fired but it goes way better than Tom
expected when Lucas pitches maybe a
promotion he's no longer feeling shiv as
CEO because she's real headstrong would
want to be doing things and he doesn't
want a partner he wants a puppet so he
offers Tom wamsgams the CEO job they
gotta keep this super secret till the
vote goes through so shiv doesn't make
any moves but it's cousin Greg with the
genius corporate Espionage opens up
Google translate and tells the Royce
siblings to get in with them now that
ship knows matson's betrayed her she's
ready to help kill the deal and they can
probably do it if the Roy's siblings are
united naming one of them as CEO they
all give their final pitches but it's
Kendall who's got the best one shiv and
Roman don't like it but they finally
agree and it's an actual beautiful
family bonding moment as the Roy
siblings messing around in their mom's
kitchen and gonna name Kendall the next
CEO and as it looks like the United
siblings are gonna come out on top they
just can't keep it together shiv and Tom
kind of apologized after their big fight
and in some ways get it all out there
has brought them closer together when
she sees her brother Kendall getting
real cocky it kind of rubs her the wrong
way and so act the board vote shiv's got
to take a minute to think it over
Kendall trying to convince her just
makes her more sure she doesn't want to
support him and the Roy siblings have
the biggest family blowout yet with the
board of directors sitting right over
there and can basically hear it all and
so they vote the Gojo deal through all
three Roy siblings are out and Tom
wamscams Dark Horse candidate coming out
of left field field is the new CEO his
best bud Greg is in big trouble for
spilling the secret early and these two
still have a complicated relationship
but in the end Tom's proud of him for
making a big move and it's like don't
worry Greg I got you and so as the Roy
siblings have lost don't feel too bad
for him they did just make a couple
billion dollars Kendall is depressed but
he'll probably bounce back and get on to
his next thing for Roman this is
probably a blessing he was not made for
that corporate world and can now just
freely be a rich douchebag Siobhan is
still in it turned Tom getting back
together but now their power Dynamic is
reversed and they're all set to continue
the cycle and raise their own kid to
probably be wildly dysfunctional and
that's where succession comes to an end